عايزه افرجكم على العالم بس بشكل جديد
شويه هنشوفه من ناحيه درجات الحراره اللي
قدامكم دي خريطه حراريه للعالم هنبداها من
سنه 1903 لحد ما نوصل لوقتنا الحالي اللون
الابيض معناه درجات حراره عاديه والاصفر
معناه مناطق دافعها وكل ما يغمق اللون كل
ما درجات الحراره بتزيد زي ما احنا شايفين
التغيير اللي بيحصل على مدار ال 120 سنه
دول العالم بمرور الوقت بيصبغ باللون
الاصفر الغامق المائل للحمره ملاحظين
التغيير اللي بيحصل يا جماعه ارتفاع كبير
في درجه حراره الارض ايوه هنقف لحد هنا ده
معناه ايه ببساطه معناه ان العالم بيولع
علشان نلاحظ الفرق خلونا جنب المشهد اللي
قدامنا ناخد لقطه لدرجات الحراره سنه 1903
كمان
[موسيقى]
ده شكل الكوكب بتاعنا في شهر يوليو 2023
وقت تصوير الحلقه دي حاليا درجات الحراره
وصلت لارقام قياسيه في عدد كبير من دول
العالم حتى بعض الدول البارده على مدار
الثعلب في مناطق في اوروبا وصلت فيها درجه
الحراره ل 48 درجه مئويه رقم ما كناش
بنشوفه في التسعينات واوائل الالفيه الا
في الخليج بس مثلا والسبب ظاهره اسمها
الموجات الحاره الموجات الحاره كظاهره
مناخيه مش هتلاقي فيها كميه الدراما
والحضور الصاخب اللي بنلاقيه في الظواهر
تانيه زي الزلازل والبراكين والاعصير مثلا
زي ما بيقول اوليفر مورتون صاحب العلوم
الشهير واحد من محرري رئيسيه لكن موجات
الحر دي قتلت على مدار العقود اللي فاتت
ملايين البشر وما زالت علشان كده بتسمى
القاتل الصامت او القاتل الخفي والظاهره
الطبيعيه دي بقت الاول واسخن واكثر شراسه
بفعل الانشطه الانسانيه الحديثه بس
اضرارها مش الاكل وبس لا موجات الحراره
الشديده مؤخرا اضرارها الاقتصاديه مهوله
وخسرت العالم في اخر 20 سنه تريليونات
الدولارات وبتاثر على بلادنا اكتر بكتير
من تاثيرها على دول العالم المتقدم اللي
هي نفس الدول السبب في اللي احنا فيه
دلوقتي فايه اللي بيحصل بالظبط وايه اللي
بتعمله موجات الحراره المهوله دي فينا وفي
العالم اقتصاديه وهل نقدر نواجهها او نحمي
نفسنا منها باختلاف ظروفنا تعالوا ندردش
شويه انا اشرف ابراهيم المقبل الاقتصادي
[موسيقى]
عايز اشكر شركه اكسنس العالميه لرعايتها
الحلقه دي وهي شركه عندها خبره طويله في
الاسواق الماليه بحجم تداولات شهريه تجاوز
الاتنين تريليون دولار ليه بنصح بالتعامل
مع اكسنس علشان اربع مميزات الاولى انها
مرخصه ومراقبه من هيئات رقبيه التانيه
بعرف اسحب فلوسي فيها بشكل فوري بدون تدخل
بشري الثالثه ان عملتهم منخفضه الرابعه ان
التداول بيتنفذ بسرعه تقدر تفتح حساب
اسلامي لا محدود وتبدا تشتري وتبيع الاسهم
والدهب هتلاقوا لينك لهم تحت الفيديو وفي
تعليقات فيسبوك تقدرنا الفرد لدرجات
الحراره مختلف تماما عن تقدير درجه حراره
الكوكب يعني ايه بقى يعني لو انت في
اسكندريه او في جده او في تونس العاصمه
مثلا ودرجه الحراره ارتفعت او انخفضت كذا
درجه فده كفيل يخليك تحس بالحر او البرد
او الجو بالنسبه لك يكون معتدل على حسب
لكن لما الكوكب كله متوسط درجه حرارته
يرتفع بنفس القدر هنا الوضع تكون مختلف
تماما اللي قدامكم ده رسم بياني في متوسط
درجه حراره سطح الارض من سنه 1880 لحد
2022 زي ما انتم شايفين
المتوسط كان تحت الصفر لحد سنه 1940
ساعتها بدات الانشطه الانسانيه في التجلي
والتاثير لما اندلعت الحرب العالميه
وبعدها رجعنا للطبيعه حوالي عقد ثم صعود
وهبوط لحد منتصف السبعينات تقريبا ومن ثم
صعود متتالي لحد اللحظه الموجات الحاره
كانت كفيله سنين اللي فاتت بقتل مئات
الالاف من البشر سنويا والامثله على ده ما
تتعدش في جنوب اسيا موجات الحر بتقتل
سنويا ما يزيد عن 100,000 شخص واحنا هنا
بنتكلم على الاعداد المسجله بس والمرصوده
رسميه في اوروبا السنه اللي فاتت بس 2022
موجات الحر الزائده مع الرطوبه قتلت حوالي
62 الف شخص والسنه دي درجات الحراره عدت
45 درجه في بعض مناطق الجنوب وعلى راس
ايطاليا اللي هي اكتر دوله اوروبيه بتعاني
حاليا من الحر وحراك الغابات اجبرت
الحكومات في كرواتيا واليونان وسويسرا
وجزر الكناري الاسبانيه على اجلاء الالاف
من السكان وعلشان نفهم تاثير الموجات
الحاره على البلاد المعتدله او البارده
هنلاقي انه مثلا اقل من 5% من الاسر في
الدول دي عاده عندها تكييف التكييف ثقافه
ما كانتش في الحسبات بالاضافه الى ان
المباني هناك في معظمها مصمم ومبني من
مواد بتحافظ على الدفء ولا تتحمل الحراره
الشديده في مدينه لوتون البريطانيه مثلا
شانيل لندن وفي ظل موجه الحر الحاليه
درجات الحراره المرتفعه القياسيه دوبت
مدرج المطار وعلقت الرحلات الجويه كذا
ساعه بينما في مناطق تانيه تشققت الطرق في
افريقيا والشرق الاوسط موجات الحاره
بتتسبب في معانات ملايين خاصه في دول وسط
وغرب افريقيا الفقيره وما فيش ارقام مسجله
تصلح اننا ن لان رصد عدد الضحايا في ظل
فقر الامكانيات الشديد هو عمليه شبه
مستحيله بينما شفنا كسكان درجات الحراره
عدت في بعض المناطق 52 درجه مع رطوبه غير
مسبوقه في امريكا موجات الحر خاصه اخر عشر
سنين بتتسبب في وفاه عدد اكتر من ضحايا
الاعاصير والفيضانات مجتمعين سنويا وفي
مدينه بورتنايت مثلا الحراره المفرطه دوبت
عدد من كابلات الطاقه الرئيسيه وده ادى
لتعطيل خدمات السكك الحديديه بينما في
جارتها كندا الاحترار تسبب في حرق اكتر من
24 مليون فدان وده رقم قياسي جديد هناك
فضلا عن اجلاء 155 الف شخص وده اكبر عدد
تجليس سلطات الكنديه بسبب حرائق الغابات
في اخر كم عقد علشان كده في دراسه مهمه
خرجت للنور سنه 2017 في نيتشرنال منصه نشر
الابحاث التابعه لقسم نتشر بورتيف
البريطانيه عملت تشريح لمئات من حالات
الوفيات بسبب الحراره خلال السنين اللي
فاتت في مناطق مختلفه من العالم وبعدها
حددت متوسط لدرجه الحراره المحتمله ثم
وضحت ان عدد البشر اللي بيتعرضوا لدرجات
حراره خطيره اعلى من المتوسط ده هم حوالي
30% من سكان العالم حاليا حوالي 2.5 مليار
شخص بيتعرضوا لدرجات حراره خطيره على
البشر لمتوسط 20 يوم كل سنه مش كده وبس
وانما الموجات الحاره الشرسه بتاثر على
المحاصيل زي ما عملت في اوروبا في 2018
ودمرت 50% من كل المحاصيل في وسط وشمال
القاره وممكن مع استمرار الموجات وزياده
وقتها كل سنه تعمل لنا ازمه غذائيه عالميه
في المستقبل القريب وده بياكد استاذ علوم
الغلاف الجوي بجامعه ليدز البريطانيه يبقى
الموضوع هنا مش مجرد موجه حر واحده وانما
موجات متتاليه سنويا بتطول مع فواصل زمنيه
غير كافيه للنظام البيئي علشان يقدر
يتعافى كل ده بياكد اننا مش بنتكلم على
ظاهره عاديه تيجي طب ايه اللي ساهم في
زياده حراره الارض بالشكل ده في الكم عقده
اللي فاته الاجابه هي احنا بمعنى ادق
تطورنا وانشطتنا واستهلاكنا للطاقه حزمه
الافعال البشريه دي انتجت الغازات الدفيئه
السبب الاساسي في الاحتباس الحراري اللي
بيرفع من شده الموجات الحاره وطولها
وتاثرها وده ياخدنا للسؤال الحلقه الاساس
النهارده ازاي موجات الحر بتاثر علينا
اقتصاديا ارتفاع درجات الحراره بيتسبب في
كبح النمو الاقتصادي لاي بلد من خلال الحد
من انتاجيه العمال وتدمير المحاصيل دراسه
شهيره نشرت في مجله ساينس ادفانسيس في
اكتوبر 2022 لاتنين من الباحثين هم جاستن
وكريستوفر كل من خلالها تاثير ارتفاع
درجات الحراره الشديده على الاقتصاد
العالمي في الفتره بين عامي 1992 و 2013
الدراسه اللي بتقيس تاثير الحراره الشديده
في المناطق البارده والدافيه على حد سواء
بتغطي حوالي 66 في الميه من سكان العالم
توصلت الى ان الاقتصاد العالمي خسر
تريليونات الدولارات من الاضرار
الاقتصاديه بسبب ارتفاع درجات حراره الارض
المؤلفين للدراسه لقيوا ان الخسائر
الاقتصاديه العالميه المتراكمه بسبب تفاقم
موجات الحر بتتراوح بين خمسه تريليون
وتسعه وعشرين ترليون دولار خلال الفتره
بين 1992 و 2013 المشكله مش في حجم
الخسائر الضخمه دي بس ولكن في مشكله اكبر
وهي ان الضرر ده منتشر بشكل غير متساوي في
جميع انحاء الكوكب في تفاوتات كبيره في
حجم الاضرار بين المناطق المختلفه في
العالم المناطق الاستوائيه الفقيره بيقع
عليها اضرار اكبر من مناطق البارده الغنيه
علشان كده الدراسه اكتشفت ان المناطق اللي
بتقع في ادنى مستويات الدخل في العالم
بتعاني من خسائر بمتوسط 6.7% من الناتج
المحلي الاجمالي للفرد سنويا ده مقارنه
بواحده ونصف في الميه بس للمناطق اللي
بتقع في اعلى مستويات الدخل الامر المثير
للسخريه بقى واللي كشفته الدراسه ان
البلدان الغنيه اللي بتعاني من اضرار
محدوده هي السبب الاكبر او المصدر الاكبر
انبعاثات غاز ثاني اكسيد الكربون والغازات
الدفيئه عموما وبالتالي فهي مسؤوله بشكل
اساسي عن الزيادات في درجات الحراره
العالميه في حين انها هي اللي بتجني
الثمار النشاط الاقتصادي المسبب
للانبعاثات دي الموضوع بالظبط كان مثلا
جيت وفتحت مصنع في الحي اللي انا ساكن فيه
المصنع بيسبب تلوث كبير بيضر سكان الحي
كلهم ولكن انا الوحيد اللي بكسب وبحقق
ارباح من شغل المصنع مش بتاثر باضراره
بدرجه كبيره الاحداث العالميه عموما سواء
طبيعيه او من صنع البشر بتكشف كل مره مدى
ترابط الشبكه الاقتصاديه العالميه يعني
مثلا لما انتشروا وباء كوفي 19 سلط الضوء
بشكل عملي تماما على العلاقه استقرار
الاقتصاد العالمي وسلاسل التوريد في سلاسل
توريد مستقره هتاخد اجمل اقتصاد على في
اضطرابات في السلاسل ومنع وحظر وحروب
واوبئه ومناخ سيء هتاخد اقتصاد عالمي
بيتمرجح وده ياخدنا لان البلاد منخفضه
الدخل والفقيره مساحتها الاقتصاديه الاكبر
هي استخراج المواد الخام غالبا والزراعه
مشى التصنيح وعندها عدد عمال في مختلف
المجالات ومن مختلف الاعمار بيشتغلوا
لتوفير المواد الخام دي في مساحات مفتوحه
بره نطاق المكاتب والشركات والعالم
المحدود ده في مزارع ومناجم وصحاري واراضي
مفتوحه ومدن ومصانع متوسطه التجهيز
والتكنولوجيا للمراحل الاوليه من اي منتج
وهكذا وبالتالي دول الاكثر عرضه لاثار
موجات الحاره الشديده السيئه بدون قدره
الدول دي على الحفاظ عليهم فاكرين دراسه
نيتشارجورنال اتكلمنا عليها في اول حلقه
الباحثين في الدراسه دي حذروا من انه على
سنه 21
وبافتراض ان الدول الغنيه عملت اللي عليها
وقللت باجراءات جذريه من معدل انبعاثات
الغازات الدفيئه نسبه التلاتين في الميه
من سكان العالم اللي عايشين في درجات
حراره خطيره قرابه شهر كل سنه هتبقى 48%
يعني نص سكان العالم وده بافتراض ان
العالم نفسه تحرك وعمل حاجه بينما لو
استمر الحال على ما هو عليه حاليا فنسبه
البشر دي هتوصل لاربع سبعين في الميه من
سكان العالم
هيقضوا قرابه شهر سنويا في درجات حراره
غير محتملها اجمالا في اهتمام متزايد
السنين اللي فاتت من موجات الحاره هو
اهتمام للامانه ما كانش هيحصل لو الموجات
دي ما ضربتش الدول المتقدمه وفضلت مقتصر
على جنوب الكوكب بس اتمنى ان العالم ياخد
خطوات متسارعه ناحيه تقنين الانشطه
البشريه والتعامل مع التغير المناخي بشكل
اكثر جديه اما بالنسبه لنا شخصيا فطبعا
هكرر لكم نصائح السلامه العامه وخدوا
بالكم جدا منها عدم الخروج وتعريض نفسنا
للشمس الا للضروره القصوى ومحاوله تجنبها
بقدر الامكان وبالنسبه لكبار السن
والاطفال فما يتعرضوش للشمس مطلقا في ظل
درجات الحراره دي وربنا يعين اهلنا اللي
بيشتغلوا في اعمال خارجيه تتطلب خروجهم
تبريد بالميه سواء بالاستحمام اليومي مره
او اثنين والاهم شرب الميه المستمر
والراقب علاماتنا الحيويه دائما خاصه
ضربات القلب والضغط مع تبريد الاماكن اللي
احنا موجودين فيها باي طريقه ناكل على قد
ما نقدر اكل صحي يساعد على تبريد الجسم او
نشرب عصائر فاكهه فريش مش هطول اكتر من
كده على لحضراتكم وكالعاده عندي سؤال لكم
تفتكروا في امل العالم واقصد الدول
المتقدمه تحديدا تاخد اجراءات جديه
للسيطره على تغير المناخ ولا ما فيش امل
وهيفضل نقاش ومؤتمرات بس للابد اتابع كل
ادواتكم في التعليقات اللي عايز يشتري
اسهم او ذهب ما تنسوش تشوفوا شركه اكسنس
هتلاقوا رابط تحت الفيديو ما تنسوش
تشتركوا في القناه ويا ريت لو عجبتكم
الحلقه تعملوا لايك وشير للفيديو واهم
حاجه تحكوا لاصحابكم وحبايبكم عننا يمكن
نستفيدوا سلام
[موسيقى]